hi christian hi nanza hey hi hey
oh christian i love everything behind
you that's so cool
thank you that's a good setup so from
the first episode i mean
everybody falls in love with gus
christian what was it like for you
playing this hybrid
um getting to play this hybrid was the
most amazing experience i've ever done
because
first of all it's so unique because
who's played
half boy half deer before so getting to
do that in his experience
was really amazing and you know it was
really challenging at first to
really get used to incorporating a boy
and a deer aspects into one character
but i really liked that challenge and i
really
liked getting to bring us alive onto
screen
well we had so much fun watching him
like i said everyone just instantly
falls in love nanza what do you love
about this series why were you excited
to be a part of it i was just really
excited to
work as soon as i got the script i was i
was
sold um the character is of tommy
jeopard that i play
is so multi-layered he's like pulling
back an
onion and what happens when you pull
back an onion there's always tears in
the end
and i think for me as an actor i really
um
relish playing characters that are
multi-dimensional you know
um you know 3d characters i guess
but i i love the story i love the
message of hope
that it gives and and the fact that it
helps us
as a society look at the way that we
treat the outsider
without necessarily singling out any of
the groups that we have in society today
yeah you know a big portion of this
series is
uh the physical aspects of it the
sequence of the action scenes what was
the training like for you guys
christian the training was
super fun for me because first of all i
got to research about deers
which is now my favorite animal and
i learned so many fun facts about them
and i had to learn their reactions and
actions and how amplified their senses
are and i had to also incorporate that
into my character so getting that
challenge was super fun
while researching fun fact um
[Music]
deer shed the rounders every spring
that's
okay that's yeah um
continuing on i also
really loved getting to do parkour
training for this role because
gus um and all the episodes at one point
is jumping off
wall it's inevitable and i had to do
parkour training for that so
i had to learn how to do certain
techniques
i had to jump off walls do stunts oh
yeah stunt training i got to do tons of
stunt training also
where they hooked me up on a wire when i
was in a harness and then they flung me
in the air in many different different
directions
and then i did all these cool stunts
like jumping onto a train
into a pile of toilet paper or running
to a 3000 foot mountain top edge
so getting to train for this role was
super fun because now here i am
talking to you about it i mean this
sounds like the coolest role
ever but you're so good now i know that
robert downey jr
is an executive producer on this did
either you get to see him on set
you know it was really tough um being we
filmed last year during lockdown
and it was it was new zealand did a
really great job of providing a really
safe
um great environment for us to be able
to be free to be creative
um robert downey jr wasn't able to come
out to be on set but he was
he gave us lots of feedback and we'd
speak to him a lot
we faced times with him and and it's the
coolest thing
in the world to say you've got iron
man's number in your phone book
you know so it's a good thing christian
how does that feel knowing that you can
just call up iron man whenever you want
it's super cool getting to know that i
called iron man because you know he's
the one
you know who's producing the show so
that's really cool
and um when i facetime them um
we really talked about the show a lot
and
we had such a great time talking and to
also to susan
so i loved getting to talk to him and
also because he's iron man
of course well you guys everyone is just
falling in love with this show
congratulations and it was such a
pleasure getting to talk to both of you
guys
thank you
you